auf schloss meseberg findet gerade die
große ampel klausurtagung stadt alles
steht im zeichen der energie krise gut
genug grund genug regal einmal ganz
genau hinzuschauen wie energie bewusst
unsere politiker dort eigentlich
hingereist sind die ganzen 70 kilometer
strecke aus berlin
neuer schock energiekrise inflation es
muss gespart werden wo auch immer es
geht ist die vorherrschende meinung der
politik und in der tat die probleme die
die ampel regierung im kommenden mangel
winter zu lösen hat sind riesig um
hilfen für die bürger zu finden trifft
sich das kabinett deshalb dieser tage zu
einer klausurtagung auf schloss meseberg
das wird eine klausurtagung wo es gute
stimmung gibt und die bereitschaft in
einer ernsten lage eng
zusammenzuarbeiten zum wohl des landes
[Musik]
aber wird dann auch gespart auf den
ersten blick nicht riesige
dienstlimousinen bestimmen wie gewohnt
das bild der ankunft der regierenden auf
schloss meseberg und die gäste kommen
auch schon mal per hubschrauber an so
klar diplomatische etikette kann nicht
so einfach weg gespart werden
luxuslimousinen und elyse statt neun
euro ticket auch mit der regionalbahn
wäre schloss meseberg von berlin aus
leicht zu erreichen
fahrzeit eine stunde 45 minuten kosten
immerhin bis einschließlich mittwoch 9
euro hin und zurück keine alternative
für das kabinett natürlich nicht es gibt
sicher sicherheitsbedenken
der finanzminister braucht gar zwei
limousinen er kommt im kongo auf schloss
meseberg an 1000 pferdestärken schlucken
sprit wie ein flugzeug
immerhin diese beiden minister sparen
treibstoff sie bilden eine
fahrgemeinschaft staatsminister und
beauftragter der bundesregierung für
ostdeutschland carsten schneider
zusammen mit kanzleramtsminister
wolfgang schmidt in einer limo
vorbildlich
kein vorbild der gesundheitsminister
kommt alleine in dicker staatskarosse
die außenministerin dicke limousine auch
kein spar vorbild und jetzt sind wir
dabei in dieser woche sehr sorgfältig
untereinander darüber zu diskutieren wie
wir ein möglichst maßgeschneidertes
möglichst effizientes möglichst
zielgenaues entlastungspaket für die
bürgerinnen und bürger und für unsere
unternehmen auf den weg bringen können
immerhin der kanzler der auch mit zwei
karossen anreiste verspricht entlastung
aber sollte die regierung nicht auch in
sachen sparen vorbild sein im postpark
gibt es sicher sparpotenzial
sternbild chefreporterin hat ja das wort
ist für uns auf schloss meseberg nach
der wir haben in dem beitrag eben
dienstlimousinen gesehen einige
teilnehmer sind mit dem helikopter
angereist sparsam sieht das für mich
ehrlicherweise nicht aus es ist ja noch
aufgefallen
hallo patricia da hast du sicherlich
recht tatsächlich den helikopter hat
pedro sanchez bin der ministerpräsident
von spanien der als gast geladen war der
ist mit dem heli gekommen und abgereist
nur tatsächlich muss man den
bundeskanzler zu gute halten dass er
dieses mal zwar mit zwei limousinen aber
wenigstens mit dem auto gekommen ist der
ist nämlich im mai als wir hier standen
um über die kabinettsklausur zu
berichten ebenfalls mit dem helikopter
gekommen und auch abgeflogen insofern er
sich zumindest da verbessert und mein
kollege albert link hat das in der
zwischenzeit bei den ministerien
abgefragt da haben natürlich viele
gesagt ja das auto ist ein arbeitsplatz
da wird vertraulich drin telefoniert
deswegen brauchen die ministerinnen und
minister ihr eigenes auto viele davon
waren mit limousinen aber in der tat wir
haben da extrem viele dicke schöne autos
vor vorne sehen ja gut für die minister
auf jeden fall robert habeck stand wegen
der gas umlage heftig in der kritik in
den letzten tagen woraufhin er
nachbesserungen versprach wie genau soll
diese jetzt aussehen
genauso gas im lager da gab es massiven
druck seitens der ampel koalitionäre auf
robert habeck und zumindest hat er sich
jetzt darauf eingelassen dass er
versuchen möchte rechtssicher zu prüfen
dass es keine trittbrettfahrer wie er
das nimmt dass es keine trittbrettfahrer
gibt das unternehmen die diese gasanlage
eben abgreifen nicht zusätzlich zum
beispiel auch noch boni ausschütten
dafür müssen die unternehmen aber erst
mal ihre bücher öffnen und wie das
gelingen soll das ist ein schwieriges
unterfangen das muss man wirklich auf
ganz feste beine stellen damit dass am
ende recht sicher wird da darf man
gespannt sein ansonsten hat habe ich
natürlich auch versprochen dass man ganz
genau hingucken wird welche unternehmen
diese umlage bekommen also sind das auch
wirklich welche bei denen russisches gas
in ganz relevanten teil im portfolio
ausmacht weil man möchte natürlich
verhindern dass dann einfach so
irgendwelche unternehmen die abgreifen
die nicht systemrelevant sind das wird
noch ein ganz schön großes stück arbeit
werden gut dass er endlich nachgebessert
hat der druck war zu recht massiv weil
sowie die gasanlage war hätte sie auf
gar keinen fall bleiben können das heißt
die unternehmen sollen jetzt offenlegen
was sie verdient woher sie das gas
bekommen oder wie genau soll man das
jetzt verstehen
genau das hat habe ich so erklärt dass
die unternehmen tatsächlich erstmal
nachweisen müssen dass sie auch einen
relevanten anteil an russischem gas
verwenden damit man sagen kann ok kommen
für die gasanlage wirklich in betracht
und dann muss sichergestellt sein dass
sie zum beispiel keine boni ausschütten
also man kann kein geld vom staat
beziehen was die gas umland und dann
gleichzeitig aber auch noch boni
ausschütten an seine an seine chefs
deswegen müssen die unternehmen dann die
bücher öffnen und das glaube ich ist ein
sehr großer schritt das recht sicher hin
zu bekommen weil keiner lässt sich gern
in seine bücher schauen und erst recht
nicht große unternehmen nach der
deutschland steckt in der teuer krise
die preise lagen so schnell auf wie seit
beginn der 70er jahren nicht mehr heute
verkündete das statistische bundesamt
dass die inflation im august den
rekordwert von 7,9 erreicht hat wurde
darüber auf schloss meseberg auch
bereits gesprochen
das ist tatsächlich ein beständiges
thema das kann aber auch niemandem
verborgen geblieben seien in den
vergangenen wochen weil der druck ist ja
wirklich massiv also so viele menschen
wissen nicht mehr wie sie ihre ganzen
kosten tragen sollen insofern besteht
hier ganz ganz dringender
handlungsbedarf das was wir vom
bundeskanzler olaf scholz heute morgen
gehört haben das waren viele warme worte
ja man weiß das alles ja man kümmert
sich der hat jetzt robert habeck eben
noch mal nachgelegt die entlastungen
werden kommen hat er versprochen wir
hören ja schon seit drei wochen es wird
an einem entlastungspaket geschraubt am
nächsten nur wann das jetzt tatsächlich
kommt dass es noch immer ziemlich unklar
dass er robert habe ich eben ein
bisschen konkreter erklärten hat gemeint
ja das entlastungspaket wird dann kommen
wenn es benötigt wird also wenn die
heizperiode losgeht wenn das jahr sich
dem ende neigt da müssen wir alle noch
ein bisschen darauf warten ebenso wie
auf das ergebnis vom stresstest und ja
also mindestens vier wochen heißt mein
eindruck gehen dann noch ins land bevor
wir wirklich handfeste sachen hören
werden ja also ich höre noch viele
offene fragen liebe nadja vielen dank
dir
sehr gern
[Musik]